if you're only using balsamic vinegar on
salad you need to reevaluate your life
or at least your recipe repertoire sure
yes balsamic is delicious on salad and
it is usually the main use for it but
I'm going to show you how to use it in a
delicious easy and festive dessert you
can make in less than five minutes let's
do it this recipe takes three
ingredients and it's all gonna blow your
mind the first strawberries next some
age balsamic glaze and finally fresh
cracked black pepper give it a good toss
and let the strawberries macerate in
their own juices with the sugar from the
balsamic all right just gonna serve this
with some fresh vanilla ice cream
sprinkle of pistachios it's spicy it's
Tangy it's sweet it's crunchy it's
creamy it hits all the marks and it
looks impossibly beautiful
mmm